et ça me fait pas grand chose vous avez
parce que en fait ce qui m'importait
c'était vraiment le film donc je sais
pas si c'était à l'air ou désagréable en
tous les cas je j'avais envie que ce
personnage soit ça donc voilà je peux
pas parler d'un sentiment d'acteur je
peux parler d'un sentiment de
réalisateurs où je suis content parce
que c'est ça que je voulais au maximum
pour faire un film comme belle et
sébastien ça m'a pris un an et demi 14
heures par jour le patient je me plains
pas du tout ce qui est formidable
là je livre le bébé est effectivement
j'essaye de monter un autre film alors
le moins agréable dans le cinéma c'est
le montage financier d'oreste j'adore ce
passionné donc j'espère pour faire un
film cet été et je suis en train
d'essayer de monter le moine voilà le
moigne que les connu acteurs donc pour
moi c'est un acteur d'abord avant d'être
un chroniqueur il y en a plein en ce
moment je le reconnais que alors le
problème c'est que je ne sais pas lire
ces l'ambulancier qui change qui chante
un peu du gloser tous acquis et démons
cet angle est il plus on
s'il n'y en bus lancé vous allez savoir
qui c'est je pense sinon voilà ça va de
radiohead metronomy n'est offert et
france d'amour c'est très éclectique la
musique classique le jazz le fric les
ont fait je suis super super éclectique
et bordélique